[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle à de
marivaux merci de nous retrouver pour
cette autre édition d' espace autochtone
en direct aujourd'hui nous allons
aborder un enjeu identitaire de taille
je dirais l'auto identification mais
avant avant parce que j'ai vraiment
envie de le faire ça ne dure que
quelques jours
voilà je vous invite à aller au 8e salon
première nation ça se passe à québec
c'est commencé depuis hier soir donc ça
vaut la peine de le mentionner
allez faire un tour si vous êtes dans la
région pour découvrir des auteurs
autochtone voilà ceci dit il ya beaucoup
de monde aujourd'hui autour de la table
pour parler d'un sujet d'un sujet qui
n'est pas évident donc isabelle picard
ethnologue bonjour isabelle éric pouliot
teasdale vous êtes chercheur en fait
recherchiste historique
voilà donc vous n'êtes pas généalogistes
on va tout de suite l'expliquer mais
vous êtes recherchiste rechercher la
liste de sites de jeux ça n'existe pas
au canada
oui mazuch investisseurs d'accor ensuite
nous avons alors là je veux dire son nom
exactement comme il faut qui jetait
alexandra veillette iso bonjour alexis
jatte et cocu et merci beaucoup de moi
je me recevoir ici aujourd'hui voilà et
nous vous recevrons parce que vous êtes
et c'est comme ça que vous vouliez vous
présentez oratrice pour sensibiliser les
gens aux cultures et réalités
autochtones m en fait ce j'aime beaucoup
présenter ma réalité et je me rends
compte que d'autres personnes là
partagent donc j'essaie vraiment de
pouvoir sensibiliser les gens là dessus
et nous allons découvrir votre réalité
au cours de cette conversation puisque
le sujet va nous y amener d'ailleurs et
puylaurens newzy ma collègue dont jours
laurence et le rang c'est avec vous que
nous allons commencer parce que c'est
vous qui avez publié cet article sur
l'auto identification de marie-josée
parents alors marie-josée par entier
conseillère de ville à la ville de
montréal qui s'occupait aussi du dossier
de la réconciliation
et puis les réseaux sociaux ont réagi
beaucoup il ya une dizaine
jour grâce ou à cause d'éric pouliot
tissu elle puisque c'est vous eric qui
avait sorti 7
ces affirmations là sur internet donc
marie-josée parents ne seraient pas ni
pack exactement inverse tude de tous les
archers publiques disponibles
j'ai pu que j'ai pu faire la généalogie
dans toute son intégrité et puis cela va
ya il ya aucun à cette attaque tonnes
d'un le côté qu'elle spéculent et du
côté de son nom puisqu'elle et acadienne
du côté de ça je savais et du côté de
son père aussi beaucoup il a quasiment
que ce soit de ce côté là mais de
spéculer que tous les acadiens sont
métis encore là c'est une excessivement
grand spéculation parce que quelques
mariages mixtes permise à quasi mais
c'est pas une généralité
donc c'est sûr c'est là que c'est allé
beaucoup trop jouer et puis on peut voir
aussi nos prières sept gouvernements à
tous que la famille haché et moi s'ils
renient mais il ya aucune mention de
2006 dans toute l'histoire des haches et
est assez bien présentés dans des sites
universitaires et gouvernementaux quant
à l'histoire de ces femmes est là et
puis absolument rien d'autre comme dans
ce malgré que certains organismes et 6
zoé preview au québec comme l'alliance
autochtones inscrit sous spi tubes que
certains seraient dans cet inconnu
serait automatiquement les autochtones
ce qui a été spéculé dans ce cas cette
fois du côté de sa mère
oui effectivement alain ançay de
l'autochtone mais en 1650
est ce que quelqu'un plus la suite
autochtone ou et c'est à partir de 1650
ça nous ramène à la 12è génération
approximativement nombre de soudou
génération a donc c'est l'image
spéculation et puis
c'est excessivement spéculatifs et puis
qu'est ce qui se passe si c'est que moi
je la connais je connais sa soeur par
exemple mais rien de probant rien
paraître
depuis plus de cinq ans par les
organismes autochtones de montréal si
dans le soulier pas particulièrement ce
n'est pas grand chose si demain
quelqu'un venait à se présenter comme
bénévole ou et participantes
c'est vraiment entre 4 et 5 ans quelque
700 jeunes vers l'identification médecis
acadie est apparu et puis à ce qu'on
peut voir depuis toutes les publications
qui a vu dans la semaine qui vient de se
passer il ya eu aucune manifestation d'
aucune n'a quasi où d'aucuns micmac des
provinces maritimes ont su par ses deux
salles oui on voit que ça sort un peu de
nulle part alors laurence vous avez
parlé à marie-josée en fait vous avez
été la seule journaliste puisque après
ça les médias se sont déchaînés et vous
avez été la première et la seule à
parler à la jeunesse et à la volée voulu
donner d'entrevue c'est-à-dire un
communiqué que les maisons ont repris
oui donc à monsieur teaser qui a fait
aussi un message énergie générée j mais
aussi madame riccio qu'il l'a fait elle
elle le fait sans le public est en fait
ok que madame reach madame riccio et
houcine est une chercheuse en général à
leur poste à la société générale
française puis on a travaillé acolytes
mince avec elles m'ont envoyé là bas
la base pour que je commence à la
recherche oui et puis à le vérifier
aussi de son côté annoncé comme cela que
ça d'accord
donc oui je sais ça vous lui avez parlé
oui marie josée je vais juillet parler
évidemment c'était une conversation pas
facile donc c'est marie josée et sa
soeur on le dit mais ça soit elle s'est
présentée aussi elle un parcours un peu
similaire te dire qu'elle a travaillé
pour des organismes autochtones ou qui
appuient les autochtones jour siéger
comme autochtone sur plusieurs conseils
et à se présenter aussi en politique
municipale faut le dire la en 2013 et se
présentait aussi comme autochtone à ce
moment là donc oui du moment qu'on n'a
pas vraiment que marie josée a su que
radio canada et sixième de jenny était
sur l'histoire elle a pris la décision
de se retirer ou du moins c'est ce qu'a
nautique
elle a pris la décision de se retirer du
dossier réconciliation c'est un dossier
que lui avaient été confiées par la
mairesse années passées où il existait
avant et donc elle a pris cette décision
là et aussi la décision de ne plus
comment s'identifie publiquement comme
autochtone oui mais elle a dit qu'elle
ne reviendrait non avec des informations
sur ce que dans plusieurs médias
français on attend toujours
mais alors qui est autochtone
quand peut-on se dire qu'on est
autochtone isabelle ça c'était la
première question d'examen et de mon
cours d'introduction au monde autochtone
que je donne à l'uqam donc cette session
si et comment est-ce qu'on identifie et
là je parle surtout des indiens inscrits
il est là et des gens tant les premières
nations et bien sûr la première réponse
et qui malheureusement c'est comme ça il
y au registre des indiens inscrits qui
existent au niveau fédéral qu'on soit
d'accord ou pas avec l'aspect coloniale
j'étais roi quand même ça il ya aussi
une appartenance culturelle qui est
important de la part de l'individu ou
c'est qu'on peut pas nier et même d un
des inscrits parfois mois d'après moi il
se qualifie pas de recette dans cette
voie là mais ça c'est une autre histoire
et il y aussi créé un jour et il ya
aussi la reconnaissance d'un groupe ou
d'une communauté par rapport à un
individu c'est à dire que par exemple si
vous parlez de moi à wendake et les gens
savent qui je suis et il ya une
reconnaissance oui ce niveau là non il
ya un peu ces trois critères alors je
pense qu'ils sont exempts important
souvent on a tendance à regarder
peut-être un peu trop sous le joug de la
carte des indiens inscrits pis pour le
reste il ya quand même des nuances à
travers tout ça c'est très complexe de
nous adaptons à cette question alors une
minute de donner une réponse très
précise mais il ya quand même des
éléments des nuances vraiment puis
j'espère que à travers la conversation
va pouvoir un peu aller un peu plus loin
deux mots et qui j'étais alexandre est
vous sentez-vous autochtone etes-vous
ordre c'est peut-être une question mais
pendant longtemps je me suis demandé
cette question là j'ai mon père oui si
je vous pose la question en réalité
c'est parce que avec ce qui est arrivé
avec marie-josée parents vous vous êtes
même vous même remise en doute
exactement j'ai comme quand j'ai vu
l'article
j'ai pas fait vraiment longtemps il
passait je me remette en question parce
que pendant longtemps
n'ayant pas été levée dans ma culture
avec l extérieur de ma communauté
je me suis je me considérais pas
autochtone en fait je faisais ce que
j'ai le droit d'aller voir ma culture
est ce que j'ai le droit de faire ça
alors je n'ai pas été élevé lada et mais
j'ai quand même vécu cette expérience de
thé d'être coupé notre culte en sarre
vient rejoindre beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes en fait beaucoup de réalités
et pourtant votre père et ottawa ont
parié se sont pas arrêtés cris et sans
m'arrêter à djibouti et se finira walder
de maraudeur d'alcanet d'affaires
autochtones est lui aussi ayant été dans
les pensionnats ya dû faire son propre
cheminement de guérison aussi eu du
travail et sur lui-même et n'ayant pas
eu
n'ayons pas appris à transmettre sa
culture oui il y aurait plus la
transmettre à ses enfants non plus mais
ils essayent aussi encore aujourd'hui
c'est un long processus aussi donc
mais il ya un an j'ai commencé à aller
vers ma culture j'ai commencé quand j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient d'autres personnes qui
étaient dans la même situation que moi
j'étais à qui il fait que j'ai pas la
seule à da que je commence peu à peu à
l'ema ma culture je commence à marcher
en tant que tout moment puis fiable de
qui je suis qui cessa de l'arctique est
sorti de chez sa mamie tout à l'envers
je le sais encore aujourd'hui avec tous
les gros débat qui est sur les réseaux
sociaux
quand vous vous comparez quand même un
os heures par an vous voyez bien qu'il
ya différence assez majeur c'est pas que
je me compare ses plus les réactions et
de l'arctique qui est qui les réactions
sur les médias sociaux qui m'ont
vraiment remis en question chez les
premières nations on est divisé aussi
par rapport à cette histoire là non oui
il ya eu une lueur commandes de ce que
j'ai vu en tout cas de facebook où des
gens avec qui j'ai parlé il ya des gens
qui se sont dit carrément trahi
oui et donc qu'ils se sont dit ben
cesser ces dames là elles sont des
alliés elles ont toujours bien fait les
choses
donc il ya un peu et il ya tout un
éventail de nuances de gris ou de
couleur en cloud est donc vraiment les
réactions elles sont plutôt partagés
à mon avis on a vu le le pas qui de
andry du domaine iard dans le devoir
aussi donc vraiment on a vraiment les
deux les deux côtés tonkam alors voilà
c'est ça le papier d'ordre est du
domaine
ailleurs qu'il a titré attendez je vais
vous le retrouver je lis si triste
tropisme où il dit qu'au delà de la
génétique est ce qu il a une pose la
question est ce qu'il serait possible de
penser autrement l'appartenance se
baissent parce que en réalité je pense
qu'il ya comme une dinde 1 le milieu
autochtone de montréal la petite
communauté
on se connaît tous très vive de 1 et
puis je peux vous dire que depuis
environ quatre ans tout le monde m'avait
dit fais de la drogue la générosité c2c
de madame des gens de plaine organise ce
qui s'affiche publiquement le des gens
qui dans nos amis communs le 10 sport
mais kim texte qu'ils unissent donc
beaucoup de monde qui veulent pas
s'afficher un peu comme on peut aller on
pourrait être un peu plus loin est long
il ya des gens qui seraient dans les
pénitenciers qui se sont auto id
assiette ac thann et tout ça et puis
ceux qui les engage sont les attaques
tonnes mais pourquoi qui les engage ses
sable fin qui ressort de chaud dans
notre milieu autochtone mariane ou
indirectement c'est un peu compliqué le
parfois c'est avantageux de remplit
toute la subvention pendant qu'elle est
existante pour profonde à perdre
fax il faut mettre un mutisme on vole
mes bêtises par de l'expression un métis
la nation spécifique des provinces de
l'ouest
donc quelqu'un de médecine ensuite
entonné avec 1 à 7 entre 1600 et 1800 à
la fcc fait parfois pour combler un
poste avec la subvention s'éteignent les
jambes des budgets de vie inscrit trois
buts inscrits sont inscrits comme c'est
la subvention n'éclatera pas ça ne soit
pas échéance
voilà c'est ça les modifications au
projet de loi et ce trois vous à risque
en plus d'amener de plus en plus de gens
qui vont se définir en tant que métisse
puis ou autres qui seraient intéressés
justement entrer dans le système bien
plus se regarder mon père examen ces
maghrébins qui est un tracteur alors je
suis un certain 21 mai carla vraiment
dans la ruche du poids et je suis un
autochtone c'est que ces cas les gemmes
parle de moi qui me représente
des fois je suis comme je suis je fais
des jeux m'occupe d'un souhaite leur du
avec une élite kahnawake asie voici
qu'un dessin d'un de inuh de la fth puis
des canaux sauter acquis points c'est
assez c'est quand j'étais quand j'étais
jeune moi je te relèves de montréal il y
avait quelques attaques temps puis
beaucoup d'autochtones qui savaient même
pas que le sang d'un métier d'acteur
d'exister à montréal parce que c'était
dingue ou deux c'était pas si miguil à
l'époque car ça les ovaires 65 65
alors donc j'étais un peu des gens qui
étaient sur elle à la dpj puis de se
défouler les fumées les six heures au
carré saint-louis à 13 14 ans à sortir
puis la police votre coiffeur nous
autres nous menotter
il nous attacher 15 minutes puis
s'appelait blues mais nous détacher
avant pour vous expliquer le contexte de
marialles dans les années 1820
c'est vraiment là qu'à partir de la
crise d'oka toute l'histoire attaque
tonnes de chemin et emi
mais a découvert pékin lui les
organismes autochtones ont commencé à
prendre des sangsues
mais avant 1990 c'était un chaos complet
à montréal coiffeur et qu'ils attaquent
hommes qui sont les autres exemples
qu'est ce que la lampe et j étais
pourrait organiser qui sont les
autochtones quand vous vous définissez
alexandra est ce que vous y si j'étais
alexandra szacka vous dites je vous êtes
autochtone comment vous présentez oui
maintenant je dis que sur la nationale
table parce que j'ai la famille au
maximum mais quand je dis encore une
fois je me remets souvent question mais
si je pense que ça va être comme ça
toute notre vie se se remette en
question tout en 2d conquête de qui on
est et c'est énorme c'est normal ou
c'est d'évoluer de changer aussi
mais pour l'instant si je m'affiche
comme autochtones des frères marx comme
auteur d'un monsieur qui je me fait
rappeler des fois ce qui est aussi j'ai
vécu une expérience en fait j'ai dû tout
c'est comme toute ma vie j'étais entre
deux mondes j'avais pas vraiment
d'appartenance entre êtres québécoise
être turtle je n'avais pas trouvé mon
appartenance etc si on se sent perdu
quand on est comme ça on sent isolé puis
on va aller vers notre culture mais l'on
ne peut pas vraiment de lien pour y
aller il y en a une on se demandait ce
qu'on y voit vraiment ce que je dois
faire ça mais à mener c'est ça j'ai
juste vu qu'il y avait d'autres
personnes dans la même situation dont
j'ai dû me léger je me suis entouré des
gens qui ont les mêmes valeurs que moi
qu'on met même expérience et ça me
rassure et puis un bon 18 commencé à les
séduire et apprendre la langue aussi
j'ai rencontré une année à m'amener que
je disais à tout âge mais tout juste de
commencer
l'un disait c'est pas qui était c'est
d'apprendre talent que celle d'être
appelé ça c'est de te rappeler de ta
culture
ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup fait du bien
d'entendre ça parce que notre culture a
nous a été dérobée et non nés comme la
génération qui essaient de même temps de
guérir on essaie d'avancer aujourd'hui
donc c'est là qu'on est encore entre
deux oui je vois tellement de gens
espérant tout de moi et ça ça m'inspire
de pouvoir le faire aussi de faire
ensemble
c'était le corps quoi qu'on va pouvoir
avancer
alors j'avais demandé à vous qui êtes
sur facebook de nous envoyer des
questions je pense que les questions
commencent à rentrer on va on va
commencer à les regarder y en aura
sûrement beaucoup on n'aura pas le temps
de répondre à tout le monde mais on
pourrait voir ce que jean françois nous
offrir non non pas encore mais encore
alors on va attendre un petit peu c'est
pas grave ça va revenir vous
oui je sais une chose je me demande s'il
faudrait pas faire vraiment séparer deux
choses des gens comme toi qui sont qui
sont en processus de réappropriation à
travers ton parent ou des gens par
exemple c'est que ce discours c'est
qu'ils ont jamais connu leur vraie mamie
dont ils sont vraiment en mode de
réappropriation ils ont été vraiment
couper là mais je pense que quand on
parle de certaines personnes comme ceux
à qui tu fais référence mais où il faut
revenir à une douzième génération pour
trouver quelqu'un de ta dans la famille
à partir du abattant deux camps j'en
suis venu à la main ça m'a mené aux
sarcasmes de tous les insectes québécois
qui ont l'avenir lévy tout le monde tout
chaque personne même les autochtones qui
ont un petit peu de saint québécois
tu fais ta g tout le monde lançait de
pedro da silva le premier facteur du
canada qui était un portugais et puis
que tout le monde est avec tout mandat
agréable martens a généré justement là
pedro da silva aussi dense et
généalogistes et les premiers colosses
la base de la fondation ski avec
française où je pourrai labassa du
portugal avec ma généalogie de dix
générations qui dit mais ce que
j'aimerais ça m'a inscrit en tant que
portugais
c'est la même chose que je trouve une
assiette en 2006 sa fille disais qu'on
veut donner votre act up ou irlandais ok
si on sait que tout les toutes les
québécois 1% à 2 5 tonnes il ya aussi
toutes les québécois 1% irlandais tout
les québécois ici 1 1% portugais seller
un peu l'impasse absolue le chaos
c'est aux autochtones de décider et puis
moi qu'est-ce que j'ai marqué d'un
travers les médias sociaux les réactions
des gens c'est que il ya beaucoup d
l'octane que des gens qu'ils kiki qui
tripent sur la question de se trouver
dans 7000 c'est tout ça et pour
s'identifier tracteurs et ce pour ce
sens c'est parce que c'est un phénomène
qui est arrivé à peu près en 1990 le
taux identification depuis la crise
d'oka tout le monde veut se trouver dans
7 octobre après la prise au cas pour
chaque crise au cas parce que pendant la
crise ne montrèrent anti ours et après
après la crise d'oka pour se
déculpabiliser inconsciemment ou
consciemment coloniale
je suis peut-être un petit peu moins
d'accord j'ai vu une grosse grosse
augmentation entre 2011 et 2016 là
vraiment il y avait lâché dans son
article de la presse parlait d'une
hausse de 149 % kiwi s'explique par deux
lotos identification et la source une
auto déclaration mais aussi par la
nouvelle loi c-3 que fait en sorte qu'il
y ait un gros pouce et d'autochtones qui
avait le droit d'avoir un stade su
qu'ils ont demandé et ça va continuer
avec la s3 qui viennent pas assez
aux mots doux maintenant l'heure où j'ai
un problème c'est qu'on questionne la
motivation de certaines personnes et
c'est ça qu'il faut regarder parce que
trop longtemps on a vu oui peut-être à
partir des zincs les années 90 des gens
qui sont tous identifiés autochtone
pourquoi pour des subventions pour des
bourses pour des postes
l'os pour payer taxes parce qu'il pense
qu'avec une carte une fausse carte
d'indiens on peut reproduire
malheureusement ils sont ils vont être
bien déçus c'est pas la réalité mais
tout ça donc des aspects essentiellement
économique
ce n'est pas la bonne raison pour
pouvoir pour vouloir être autochtone ça
pour moi c'est alors que dans le code et
200 pages une panse peau que leur
motivation elle était à cet effet le
bien soit ait eu des bénéfices manger
terrain mais je pense pas que leur
motivation première elle est elle donc
il ya vraiment des côtes figurent qui
sont absolument à le courir de nouveau
oui j'ai les ai rencontrés bienvenus
quand j ai vu je voyais vraiment que la
bonté vie pouvoir aider aussi les jeunes
j'ai rencontré deuxième parent quand
elle a donné des ateliers pour la
formation sont pour le climat je faisais
partie des keys autochtone casa
d'automne qui se sont réunis un jour
avoir la grande marche sur
l'environnement fille c'était tellement
une femme inspirante que c'est ça l'est
toujours selon moi je trouve que l avait
de bonnes intentions et quand j'ai vu
l'article
je sais encore une fois ça me remet en
question si mais surtout parce que je me
demandais magie impression pour avoir
toutes les pièces du casse tête que je
veux savoir pourquoi
pourquoi cette sortie c'est pourquoi
pourquoi que vous voyez je me posais pas
de questions scénographie surtout que
c'est si il y avait des intentions
malignes ça ça m'aurait beaucoup blessé
mais pour l'instant c'est parce que j'ai
ressenti en rencontrer l'homme mais là
pourquoi ces sorties parce que des gens
vous ont posé la question parce qu'on
vous avez un cardiaque à tout le monde
notamment que beaucoup de bien des
regrets parce que je faisais partie du
réseau
j'ai directement cette année donc voilà
fac et puis moi qu'est ce qui est arrivé
c'est que en 2006 2000 à partir de 2006
jusqu'à 2008 à peu près j'ai fait une
étude sérieuse et qu'elle veut jeter
d'alice demeurer à ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne connaissaient pas karim est
intégré aux organismes autochtones
pierre lacroix au delà full attack tas
de montréal il ya un professeur
universitaire de l'université laval qui
m'avait subventionner une recherche pour
vous dire il va suivre maintenant que
médecin juste pour voir comment les gens
parce que vous n'êtes pas qu'un registre
et parce que ma g à l'histoire de
pensionnés puis subit les adoptions
ça a pris 14 heures d'affaires indien
dames 1 2 de sortir toutes les documents
gaieté nécessité pour les familles se
veut s'était jamais à changer natale et
documents et ce tout le monde était
perdue même ira chercher ses affaires
docteur aura donc par là cette période
là il m'a dit faufile toile à une
identité métisse improvisé puis demande
aux organismes de montréal
des dettes incorporé dans ces organismes
nous lâche tout les résultats
et finalement ça le prix à peu près vers
environ 2014 2015 les organismes
commencent à être un peu plus prend ce
qui séduit comme quoi le fait que les
gens qui arrivent avec des cartes métis
ça marchait plus et sam mais plutôt au
moins j'ai fait mes recherches
généalogiques j'ai ouvert un site
internet pendant cette étude le puis je
demandais aux gens si vous voulez que je
fasse vérification de généalogie au
québec et ça vaut en 7 octobre
et puis j'ai fait un agglomération
similaire à darwin vous comme on a vu
dans son livre d'avis que la bohème en
partie le mans series beaucoup de gens
spéculent à voir les gars 7 octobre
comme il a le regard de ces appels de
l'alliance un tracteur du québec qui ont
environ 40000 membres et puis on sait
que l'organisme qui s'appelle les
habitants métisse du nord du québec qui
donne les les loyers à loyers des
logements à loyer modique pour les
autochtones aux réserves en réserve
oui c'est en réalité un coup monté de ce
groupuscule qui s'appelle l'alliance a
doctor du québec qui gère les habitants
métisse du nord avec des financements
des enfants autochtones du canada et du
ministère l'habitation un provincial et
c'est tous des gens de l'alliance
autochtones du québec il ya un truc
tonnes par ci par là mais toutes leurs
budgets sont
on regarde ça s'appelle wachkyrie guen
les habitats métisse du nord sur google
les budgets d'ailleurs à tout et tout
est disponible sur google c'est assez
ahurissant et puis qu'est ce qui se
passe ici avec ce phénomène là c'est que
personne ne veut vraiment aller dénoncer
la gestion les dénoncer la compagnie
fermer tous les habitants métisse du
nord provinciales vont fermer
exactement danse un peu sur dd sur des
aiguilles avec l'aspect dénoncé à ça
j'ai pas vu les chefs autant à la pnq
elle que les chefs des communautés
prendre une position là dessus ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'on a des gens de
soubresauts de ces pleurs puis il y aura
de la difficulté je pense à prendre nos
positions mais c'est un doux ce qui
devient politique tant qu'à moi ils vont
devoir un peu le choix de se pencher là
dessus
la question d'identité d'autant plus
avec la c3 la s3 janeiro le taux
identique à sion avec de tout ce dont on
vient de parler il ya d'autres nombreux
estime que c'est pas c'est pas les seuls
l'histoire part donc donc il va falloir
vraiment prendre une position
est ce que on peut adopter ont
symboliquement certaines personnes qui
sont à l'automne mais qui sont qui
respecte la philosophie les préceptes
bon match et herat est ce que ça
pourrait pas être fait pour l'instant il
n'y a rien donc un autre de 1 entre deux
chaises qui crée beaucoup de malaises
mais beaucoup de dissensions je pense
que les chefs vont devoir s'y attarde y
avait plus il y avait plus eu de
condamnation car il veut reportage cib
ici sur les fausses cartes ou même quand
on avait parlé il avait lâché dans la
presse qui avait parlé de défaut sont
encore en prison l'oeil avec +1 un
malaise je sais pas si on parlait des
motivations je pense qu'un éventail
énorme de motivation de s'auto déclaré
autochtone je dire on parler d'erreur
leroux énormément parler oui des
désorganisations allons qui il est
c'est un professeur à halifax que
beaucoup écrit sur l'auto autochtones
isation déry shifting puis il parle
beaucoup des organismes qui se déclarent
à 8,6 au québec mais qui il a beaucoup
d'entre eux qui vont en cours et c'est
délirant quiz et c'est d'aller en cours
pour ce faire dé reconnaître politis et
donc pour avoir les mêmes droits que les
autochtones et droit de chasse et de
pêche
mais en même temps ils tous ces gens là
qui ont des cartes de ces organismes là
donc
certains vont se déclarer autochtone ils
vont peut-être prendre la place d'un
devrait de tonnes à la fonction publique
mais il ya aussi d'autres
puis on en connaît à marie toi et moi
qui ont leur carte mais qui font rien
avec nécessairement ils ont choisi le
dire il faut le mentionner dans un
besoin dans un souper de famille qui
sont adoptables mairie ils vont pas
aller plus loin
ça s'entend tous quand je parle de
l'appartenance que vous aurez l des fois
que ça vaut un peu dans les deux sens
enfin moi j'ai entendu des autochtones
d'heure ben moi j'ai une carte puis je
paie pas de taxes c'est tout ça s'arrête
là j'ai un problème aussi avec ça ne se
peut pas si on compare les deux
approches dix ans par un avec cette
personne là honnêtement il faut vraiment
réfléchir à cette question le identité
c'est complexe et pas juste une question
de st alors on a reçu une question qui
arrivent des réseaux sociaux comment
expliquer les vieux recensement où il
semble y avoir des mentions de métis au
québec qui peut y répondre
peut-être que ce sont eux aussi ça
demande un peu spéculatif selon la
perception de la personne qui faisait
recensement est ce que il est associé à
ces familles là avec les les familles de
louis riel puis de ceux qui sont partis
fonder la nation métisse vers l'ouest où
c'était une expression commune à
l'époque dans ce secteur à le signifier
mariage mines issue d'un mariage mixte
réunion mixte c est une spéculation
mondiale fac de dire c'est ça ou c'est
sûr ça
seulement ce trop loin parce que la
constitution canadienne reconnaît trois
groupes autochtones les indiens donc les
premières nations les inuits et les
métis né on parle des métis du peuple
mais chief non mais des descendants de
louis riel dans l'ouest du nord ouest
essentiellement il y en aurait l'ontario
m reste essentiellement canadien donc
probablement que on parlait de mixage
donc comme moi je suis métisse et mais
je suis pas médecin c'est une espérance
parce que j'ai remarqué j'ai fait la
liste démographique complète de
kahnawake kanepi qui a causé ce n'est
souvent l'expression mitis est exposé
justement quand c'était un mariage mixte
avec une canadienne française ou
anglophones
or donc mais avec savait rien à voir
avec la nation médecin qui a été fourni
d'un joueur je reviens à ma question
tout à l'heure parce que bon nous reste
c'est comme un autre dossier quand on
parle des métis mais quand on parle des
gens qui se disent métissée au québec on
devrait remonter jusqu'à quelle
génération pour dire ah mais oui nous
sommes
et là moi je pense que si on peut
développer de langue de culture
particulière c'est nul de nullité moi
j'ai moins dix ans j'ai eu un sage et
une quatrième génération disons
portugais mais j'suis pas portugais pour
ceux qui en génération c'est une
inversion pas du tout ça se termine
demain
moi je pense que pitié riez direct et de
reconnaissance de la première nation
d'origine ou dans la communauté
d'origine
je pense qu'à ce moment là on se trompe
oui pour ce qui concerne les soeurs
parents personne chez les micmacs de
l'est en fait de la gaspésie puisque
d'avoir des mi'kmaq sont dans cette
région là ne sont venus défendre
l'appartenance des soeurs parents à ces
communautés là exactement puis un mois
cela au moins moralement par vingt sept
ne reçut patients d'identité on n'arrive
pas dans un organisme peut dire je suis
moi
lens est pedro da silva je pouvais aller
demain au conseil de l'organisme
portugais l' église visée de vie normale
je me sens portugais jury quand je
marche dans votre quartier je verse à
mes ancêtres
c'est ce qu'ont à avalon question voyez
vous que cette recherche d'un métissage
généralisé chez les canadiens français
servent à se déculpabiliser du
colonialisme on l'a abordé un petit peu
tout à l'heure mais hélas et puis les
gens qui disaient sur les photos
regardent ils ont tout bronzé il marche
de table tous les québécois travaillent
dehors tout l'été il était bronzé toute
l'année parce qu ils t'adorent toute
l'année et à tout bronzé sur les photos
et tout le monde m'a chef du tableau 8e
manche mais des pipes 2 tab
c'était une grande masse pis d'ailleurs
près de la première guerre mondiale tout
le monde devait culture est certaine un
certain nombre d'offres de tabac c'était
non gouvernementales d'agriculture
d'époque comme le chante pour faire du
riz libre arbitre
donc tout le monde doit en tout le monde
était bronzé et tout le monde fumait des
pipes de tabac par les gens voient des
photos que désormais regarder et à brens
ils étaient bruns maintenant l'état
directement mais produire la question
d'erick est ce que c'est pour se
déculpabiliser du colonialiste j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui va se déculpabiliser on est les
trucs du passé on essaie en vain des
excuses comme dépense énorme et ça donne
ça va aider à nous et qui nous donnait
trois commentaires là j'ai beaucoup
d'émotion mais je trouve que en premier
il faudrait juste travailler ensemble au
lieu d'essayer de pointer du doigt des
gens essaient de se trouver une identité
ou si je pense en premier vous juste
discuter comme on fait en ce moment
parce que temps ensemble et
c'est comme ça je laisse à mon cas
isabelle vous je ne saurais pas vraiment
quoi ajouter à ça c'est peut-être parce
que je réponde pas c'est que c'est
peut-être pas le bon moyen donc de
s'auto identifiés pour se déculpabiliser
d'un certain colonialiste s'éduquer
selon moi ça serait dans la lah la
solution numéro un la base il y voilà
c'est ce que j'aurais alors tout à
l'heure vous avez dit on a fouillé les
soeurs parents parce qu'on nous l'a
demandé mais il y en a d'autres
ah oui oui on a beaucoup d'humour on
n'est pas là pour s'amender que ce soit
mais y en a tant que symbole eux ces
imams sous oui oui
puis des gens qui quitte à les vaincre
et un paysan des gens ils font les
expositions à des universités de saint
josse et à ccc plus que les gens peuvent
penser
puis étant donné que bon tout le monde
se connaît dans nos organismes
montréalais
puis je pense que les trucs que je vais
faire ça va être une très bonne très
bonne façon de voir les zappeurs les
organismes disait que j'étais mais il
n'y avait pas de règles
puis on n'a toujours pas partout encore
se peut toujours arriver au sein de
l'amitié puis s'inscrit à toutes sortes
d'activités en disant tiens je suis un
lien 7 octobre puis déjà il n'y a pas
c'est pourtant un service c'est 2% la
population à 4 pour cent au canada au
québec le sait la plus petite population
quant aux prédateurs c'est peu après un
apéritif de l'effet qu'elle les gens
savent poteau sur quel pied danser avec
des cartes autochtone dans les commerces
insultes de ce
fait que je pense que vraiment il faut
il faut que nos organismes
c'est un peu la ceinture oui il ya des
gens qui vont venir participer comme les
100 par an il est en fait de l'excellent
travail
j'ai rien à dire sur leur travail le
travail est excellent mercredi
revirement qui met un stop à d'acide en
suis à l'histoire de tom de deux
collaborateurs je suis très bienvenue
aux collaborateurs les amours supporter
d'identité gogo je pense que c'est ce
que ça dépasse les bornes
et si quelqu'un d'autre je pense que lon
accueilli 25 ans tous les gages c'est
une passion alors si quelqu'un d'autre
avait fait cette recherche généalogique
qui devancerait arriver au même résultat
que vous exactement hockey lorsque la
question de maya est la suivante quelle
est la marge d'erreur des recherches
généalogiques au québec mais infecte et
par année qu'on n'a pas eu des guerres
au québec paie que les églises n'ont pas
brûlé comme en europe avec les première
deuxième guerre mondiale est pressé m
tous les gens sont là et puis pour que
l'écurie continue d'obtenir les
allocations de terre par l'intendant
pouvoir développer leurs
les clergés au québec français leur
tâche c'était de régir de stern et sur
la population côté démographique via les
registres paroissiaux les baptêmes les
décès les naissances et participe
également recensement or donc il fallait
absolument garder un oeil sur tous les
membres des populations autochtones
parce que si elle voudrait voir une
révolution ou n'importe quoi une
guérilla éventuel quelque chose dont je
vais tout le monde avait une heure sur
toutes les populations ont cure oui un
cadeau remonte jusqu'au début de la
colonie tout y est vrai est également on
ne tout tout tout tout il ya quelques
paroisses qui ont été inondées ou des
trucs comme ça mais c'est tellement taux
d'intérêt minimal on a vraiment un tout
puis dorénavant tous les microfilms
paroissiaux les registres paroissiaux
des buts en 740 avec ce matin' 20 c
public jusqu'en 1940
normalement le décret de deux
publications sesat 1 avant notre année
mais étant donné que les collections ont
été achetés tous les bébés mais public
jusqu'en 1940 le recensement et jusqu'en
1921 normalement ça se calme 1919 on est
un de ses sauts mais j'ai une question
pour un excellent démission parce qu'on
sait très bien que vous parlez plutôt de
broyat plusieurs com com
notre de la jeune lauréate la mission
c'était démission est ce qu'on nous
raconte tout ce registre là dans de
toutes les missions je les ai dit oui
oui tout y est tout et c'est ce qui
manque certaines d'animer à faire à
l'inversé la semaine on peut adresser
tout le monde
ok c'est cool oui exactement alors oui
mais je peux quand j'avais interviewé
dominique et toi ouais mais discours de
louis et tous les deux m'aviez dit quand
il y avait une union entre une femme
autochtone est un homme canadien
français mais ton était et vous deux
vous avez dit c'était écrit jeu là les
curry avait aucun avantage à cacher ce
genre de choses
alors que denis delage je me suis la
vente en dessous 15,8 il dit contraire
boissons que tous les autres cherchent
et son université dans des ruelles où
tout le monde
on est toutefois d'accord condamné d'un
lounge qui dans un espèce de fantasme un
peu avec en tout cas c'est ce que tout
le monde pense d'un millier
d'universitaires qui ont signé ce qui me
sidère âge est un peu puis est associé à
des groupuscules indépendantistes
dessous j'ai été dans quels cas de ces
conférences poser des questions cela
crée des gants des bottes je veux or
voilà enfin que c'est un peu discutable
je dénie poju parce que c'est évidemment
il ya fait d'excellents avait avoué
sauf que je pense que l'émotion qui
entrent en ligne de compte mais
annihiler les bons résultats
scientifiques ce2 et à une personne non
académique si je me demande si jamais je
me demande tout le temps
est ce que est ce que la loi d
intermarché à certains moments ce que
c'était vraiment pour effacer les
autochtones lecteurs ce que c'est a très
bien demander des choses est que plus
craquer j'acquiesce il voulait briller
en garde est négatif surtout de garder
vie
je me demande à chaque jour à ce que ça
se peut que certains secteurs comme avec
la discrimination discrimination envers
les femmes en moi ça se peut que ce soit
pas enregistrées je me demande à chaque
jour pitié comme le monde qui était au
pensionnat je vais trouver des familles
de kahnawake qui ont été adoptées vu que
les premiers pensionnaires anglophone ça
a été développé avec les mois que les
abénakis est envoyé à sault-sainte-marie
temps de ski au québec ça se développer
plus avant 1940 les passionne
francophone
donc il ya 10 22 kahnawake qui les gens
disaient vos enfants sont décédés il
osera enfin opération décédé puis les
ont fait de terre sainte marie j'ai raté
à ces deux de ces familles le psg privé
pour le journal iraq et puis finalement
je veux les familles se sont joints mais
tout était écrit par exemple encore ne
s'était pas caché dans l'énergie dont
tahri aucun lien son mari s'il était
écrit madame fille de telles personnes
de kahnawake
et puis on entend ça n'est plus associée
en amont et tout et tout est public les
mains dans une question intéressante
elle et elle est pour vous une question
de catherine je me reconnais dans les
sentiments identitaires de pige à thé
comment réussis tu as trouvé un
équilibre dans tout ce que tu ressens
pas ce que je sais trouver un équilibre
tout ce que je ressens j'ai l'impression
que j'ai pas de calais en fait j'ai tous
les jours je me demande je change de
comment je peux dire je me remet tout en
question mais je pense que c'est ça
justement il ne pas se remettre en
question quand c'est aussi clair dit
claire j'ai l'impression que ce n'est
pas pour bonne mais comme j'ai dis
qu'est ce qui m'a aidé à garder cet
esprit matin de rester avec les gens qui
partagent la même expérience que moi de
me retrouver avec ces personnes ne sais
j'ai commencé mais être plus impliqué
dans le milieu autochtone ou si on
partage nos histoires ça nous fait du
bien de partager plus de se faire
écouter qui est tout ça à montréal j'ai
commencé à être appliquée avec montréal
autochtone au début puis j'ai rencontré
d'autres jacquet qui équipent de la
communauté de montréal qui ont les mêmes
questionnements donc on se parle ans
on fait c'est ça qui me permet d'avancer
je pense que beaucoup de docteurs qui
passe à travers cette phase là moi aussi
je passe et d'une mère québécoise puis
ce qui fait en sorte que moi j'ai réussi
je suis plus plusieurs victoires mais ce
que j'ai réussi à faire en fait c'est
quand quand j'ai commencé à connaître ma
culture ma langue
le territoire davantage vers le
territoire mon par miam n'est plus temps
mais la culture commune étaient dépensés
par les pensionnaires savait était
complètement passé à côté donc donc en
apprenant l'histoire la culture les
racines en est en étant fier en parlant
avec des années bon état mais ce
cheminement l'oeil se fait pas du jour
au lendemain et c'est pour ça que
l'identification autochtone par souci
par le côté socioculturel qui est
tellement important le côté spirituel
mais aussi qui est extrêmement important
puis quand on est élevé à l'extérieur de
la communauté parfois on en a moins
un lien direct avec tout ça donc il faut
travailler doublement fort pour essayer
de retrouver tout ça et c'est là qu'on
voit j'imagine à être plus fort plus
alors pour l'instant je vois pas
d'autres questions on termine bientôt
l'émission dont de toute façon il va
bientôt trop tard pour poser une
question
mais ce phénomène d'auto identification
il est beaucoup plus important dans les
milieux urbains qu'à l'extérieur n'est
ce pas la réalité elle est plus dans les
milieux urbains
c'est quand même variable c'est vraiment
parce que je sais qu'il regroupe le
domaine de voir de l'annoncé par même
sur la côte nord
beaucoup qui sont venus traquer jusque
là population et les huit assaillants
ici dans ce fourre tout mais partout et
la cie ont creusé dans la généalogie
évidemment on aurait baissé ceux qui se
passionnent il ya des gens qui sont
injectés dans un organisme métis micmacs
de la quasi epr usé mais leurs ancêtres
adam qu'il ya des gens qui sont à
rejeter les métis de val d'or mais que
leur enfant est un hack asie ça n'a
aucun sens de l'histoire mais pas
n'importe quelle race avec un taux qui
est autochtone un bowling faut
questionner les motivations d'un stand
et voilà il faudrait donc les
représentants autochtones les chefs
mortiers se posait même caisse je pense
qu'il remporte choix moment donné de se
pencher sur le sujet ça devient trop
important c'est des gens comme je disais
tout à l'heure qui vont aller chercher
des subventions qui vont garder les prix
qui vont faire des conférences au nom
des autochtones qui vont prendre des
positions publiquement ça peut être
extrêmement dérangeant extrêmement
dangereux aussi
j'ai fait des travaux il ya quelqu'un
qui passe cammas th c'est vraiment
spécial a master parce quelqu'un qui ont
créé des réserves bientôt il y avait il
y avait environ 40% de la bd qui est
rentrée mais avec tout le dessin d'un
présentement c'est comme au moins 40% de
besné qui dans cette devinez qui il
reste hinault et puis il ya des gens qui
depuis que ce sétois et astro ils ont
juste un an 7 abénakis mais sont
enregistrées comme montagne hamas th
ryanair qui m'appellent annie c't'un
gars d'une prison qui remplissait son
formula d'emploi qui me dit est ce que
j'écris à biner kivu montanier mais j'ai
décidé c'est faux
mais nous allons peut-être un jour
revenir je pense que ce sera inévitable
merci à vous tous d'avoir participé à
cette discussion et a donc laurence
newzy journalistes
l'espace autochtone qui jatte et
alexandra beier jve merci mec l'infini
mende est devenu aujourd'hui éric
pouliot teasdale et isabelle picard que
nous n'aurons pas la semaine prochaine
mais la semaine prochaine donc on
s'intéresse à la formation du nouveau
gouvernement de justin trudeau
donc nous allons en discuter avec alexis
one all what et cindy world et je le
vous y attend merci beaucoup
[Musique]